Ngay mục tâm thẳng từ chúng tâm bảo tồn gồn cúc ra chạm chim tình đồng thác cho biết,
đang chim bồn nông trên 3 vừa suyển tại KU Amod sau sáo năm bản bảo.
Đây là khu vực bảo tồn nghiêm ngặt của vừa cúc ra chạm chim,
đang chim bồn nông trên 3 vụng sau các thế đã xuống khu vực đâm lời để ki.
Bồn nông trên 3 là lại chim quy yếm, quy cấp, năm trong xách nỏ Việt Nam và xách nỏ thế giới,
rau suy giảng nghiêm trọng về suy lợ.
Lой này có đặc biệm nhận giảng lại trên 1 3,
chưa dài thân từ 1 vụ hay 2 đến 1 vụ tư mẹ, chân có mạng bơi,
mỏ dài với tuy ra lớn bên dưới có thể giảng rộn về trước cả.
Chúng thường sống và kia măng theo đàn.
Đây là lại chim nước gì cư coi yêu cầu cao về mua chương sống,
đặc biệt có thể những khu vực có không dàn thẳng,
muốn thức ăn dồi dạo và ít bị tắt động.
Bây giờ, sự quay trở lại của lại chim này cho thấy điều kiện xinh thái tại chạm chim,
đang từng bước được cái thiệt.
Là tin hiệu ở phần khởi cho không tác khu vụ hệ xinh thạm.